MINH NGUYEN: Hi.
And welcome to "The future
of application development
with cloud databases."
My name is Minh.
And I'm a product manager
for Cloud Firestore.
Join with me today and Natan,
a software engineer from Dott.
Today's session will be focused
on resolving one key question--
why is it so challenging to
build and scale applications?
And more importantly,
what is Google
doing to make application
development easier?
To answer this
question, we'll begin
by reviewing two popular
application architectures.
Choosing an architecture
has a large impact
on how an application is
built and how it scales.
In the second part
of the session,
you'll hear a
customer testimonial
from Dott describing how
thoughtful architectural
decisions have impacted
their business.
Finally, we'll round out
the session with new product
announcements and resources
to learn more about Firestore.
Let's get started.
Imagine for a moment that
you're writing a new application
and decide to use a
more traditional n-tier
architecture.
Today's example can apply to
any general purpose application,
but to ground the
discussion let's
assume it's an e-commerce app.
At the heart of the
application is a database.
The database is
used to store data.
In front of the
database are typically
a set of microservices that
manage your application's
business logic.
Let's assume that you have
three separate microservices--
a service for your
product catalog,
a service for your product
inventory, and lastly a service
for your shopping carts.
As usage for your microservices
grow and declines,
you'll need to load
balance traffic
while horizontally scaling
and compacting capacity.
In order to secure access
to these microservices,
you'll need to add
an API gateway.
Finally, to enable
broad distribution
of your application, you'll
need to develop clients--
the web, Android, and even iOS.
Furthermore, you want to make
sure that your users always
have the latest data.
To access your application
when they're offline,
you'll need to add
support for web sockets
and an offline caching system.
As you can see, there's a lot
of technical complexity here.
Unfortunately
technical complexity
can be the enemy of
business innovation.
Let's examine the downstream
impact this architecture has.
First, operationalizing
all the services
that support an application
can be intensive.
Second, each layer
of the architecture
typically represents
specialized teams,
which means complex
dependency planning
and therefore potential
risks for project delay.
Third, sourcing talent for
each layer of the architecture
can be difficult and
expensive, especially
in competitive hiring
markets like today.
Let's figure out how
Google is solving
for each of these
challenges, starting
with the operational challenge.
Google offers
management services
for each layer of the stack.
With Cloud SQL, for
example, we will assist you
in operationalizing popular
relational databases
such as PostgreSQL, MySQL,
or even Microsoft SQL.
With Kubernetes Engine,
we will assist you
in operationalizing
your microservices.
With Apigee, we will assist you
in operationalizing your API
gateway.
So the combination of these
management services from Google
will assist you in
operationalizing
each layer in the stack
while still enabling
high customization.
Alternatively, if you're
interested in taking
the surplus route,
you can use Cloud Run
to run your microservices in
Firestore as your database.
Choosing to go the
serverless route
allows you to delegate
operational complexity
to Google, freeing
up your team to focus
on product development.
OK.
We've addressed
operational complexity,
but what about projects
or hiring complexity?
Let's examine how a deeper
investment in Firestore
can address the
remaining challenges.
Firestore is a serverless
document database
that can also act as a
complete backend as a service.
Firebase Auth is a
service that allows
you to delegate your
applications auth and user
management to Google.
Firestore and Firebase Auth
are seamlessly integrated.
Using a combination
of these two services
allows customers to
focus on UI development,
delegating secure auth and
backend service management
to Google.
Furthermore, you'll get
built-in functionality
for real-time synchronization,
connection management
between clients
and your database,
and offline caching
using the Firestore SDKs.
So by using Firestore as
a backend of the service,
you can focus on UI development.
And UI teams are empowered
to make decisions,
as they no longer are dependent
on changes from backend teams.
With universal
application frameworks
like Google Flutter
or Facebook React,
you can now write
native applications
using a single code
base and deploy them
across multiple client platforms
such as the web, Android,
and iOS.
Firestore fully supports
these universal app frameworks
with an easy-to-use
set of plain SDKs.
As a result, with Firestore
and universal app frameworks
you can focus on hiring
for Flutter or React skills
from a very large
pool of developers.
The result of these
investments enables
you to focus on
business innovation
through a single autonomous
team and code base.
There are many factors that go
into application development.
And at Google, we're investing
in a complete ecosystem
for app development.
This includes, one, core
UI frameworks and operating
systems to build
applications, two,
in-app services from Firebase
to manage aspects like auth,
and three, backend
services from Google Cloud
to manage aspects like
back office analytics using
BigQuery.
Firestore brings together
these portfolio investments
in an intelligent way by
enabling seamless integration
into each of these portfolios.
Frequently applications rely
on third-party services,
and it's important that these
services are also seamlessly
integrated with Firestore.
One popular integration
request we've received
has been an integration
with Elastic.
Today, we're excited to
announce, in partnership
with Elastic, a
new extension that
streams changes from
a Firestore database
to an Elastic app
search instance.
You can install this extension
and many other third-party
extensions from the Firebase
extensions directory.
So in summary, Firestore
allows customers
to focus on business value
and product differentiation.
[INAUDIBLE] document database
that can also act as a backend
to service.
With over 250,000 monthly
active developers,
you can have confidence
that the solution
is backed by a large
community of developers.
Furthermore, with
Firestore applications now
supporting 750 million monthly
active end users using Firebase
Auth, you can be confident
that Firestore will
scale to your business's needs.
We've covered the
traditional n-tier
in Firestore architectures.
Let's review the
strengths of each.
The traditional n-tier
offers a high customizability
and is compatible with
popular open source frameworks
and libraries.
However, as we explained
in this session,
this normally comes at the
trade-off of technical,
project, and hiring complexity.
Pricing for this
solution is often
driven by a capacity
model, which
means that you have to configure
how capacity is scaled,
and you're billed for
capacity even when
it's not fully utilized.
Firestore, on the other hand,
provides a fully integrated,
Google-based solution
that significantly
reduces technical, operational,
project, and hiring complexity.
Customers who choose
Firestore have the flexibility
to use it as a
backend of a service,
in an n-tier architecture, or
maybe a hybrid of the both.
Since it's serverless,
pricing for Firestore
is based on the actual
operations conducted, storage
used, or network egress.
And with that I'm excited
to introduce Natan
from Dott, who will share
how Dott uses Firestore.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATAN SAGOL: Good morning.
I'm Natan, one of
the engineers who
joined Dott at the very
beginning of our journey.
We are a micromobility operator
with over 50,000 e-scooters
and e-bikes across
45 cities in Europe.
We are active in nine countries,
in capitals like London, Paris,
and Warsaw, and
many more cities.
I have been fortunate
to participate
in growing our company
from the very first scooter
to tens of thousands
we operate today,
to see our engineering
organization expand to over 30
people--
looking forward to
welcoming many more
before the year's end--
to enable millions
to take clean rights.
At Dott, we deeply care
about the environment,
and we try to reduce our carbon
footprint as much as possible.
While Google Cloud
is carbon neutral,
it's even better not to
consume any kind of resources
in the first place.
That's why we
choose technologies
which rapidly up and downscale
to precisely match our needs.
Firestore is one of
these technologies.
It has been a core
to our solutions
from the very beginning.
We started on Firestore by
connecting our vehicles, which
frequently send information
about their location
and relevant telemetry.
We quickly moved to
user-facing features,
using Firestore as a backend.
Connecting to it
directly from our apps
allowed us to work
efficiently and independently.
We were a small team back then.
Removing the need for
any backend development
allowed us to shift
features quickly.
In a single day with
real-time synchronization,
we were able to implement
a vibrant live map
of available scooters.
Over time, we added
many functionalities,
from basic ones like
starting and ending
a trip to more complex, such
as payment processing, where
accuracy is critical.
For these
functionalities, Firestore
provided us not only with an
ability to develop rapidly,
but with an ability to
develop with confidence,
allowing us to
ensure correctness
with the use of transactions.
The world changes all the time.
So does our business.
More sophisticated
functionalities
require specialized services.
We have developed
a lot of these,
and each time Firestore has
proven to be a good fit.
Some of these services replaced
directories from our apps
when we needed complexity
that was easier to manage
with a dedicated backend.
But we are grateful
we didn't have
to implement all of
this back in the days
when there were
just a few of us.
Some of the recent
changes we all experienced
were challenging for individuals
and businesses alike.
Shelter-in-place
orders, while necessary,
affected every one of us and
affected a lot of companies,
including Dott.
Our choice to utilize Firestore
and our serverless products
helped us navigate
shelter in place.
With the lower usage came a
lower bill with the expected
one-to-one correlation.
Nowadays many lean more towards
individual transportation,
such as with the use of
e-scooters and e-bikes
due to health safety reasons.
At Dott, we see many more
riders and trips in comparison
to pre-COVID numbers, with
utilization of our fleet
75% higher in some
cities such as Brussels.
Scalability of
Firestore enabled us
to support this demand
without requiring
any changes on our side.
As regard to our
infrastructure, we simply
don't have to worry
what happens next.
Firestore will
adapt to our needs
and support us in our journey.
Now that you know a bit
more about our history,
it's a good time to
share with you what
I think about it in retrospect.
While at the beginning we were
considering other databases--
relational, graph, and
document oriented--
today I know that we
couldn't have made a better
choice than Firestore.
That's why it's such a
pleasure for me to be here
today and give this testimony.
Thank you all.
And thank you, the
Firestore team.
Back to you, Minh.
MINH NGUYEN: Thank you, Natan,
for sharing Dott's journey.
I'm excited about Dott's
impact on the future
of transportation.
We appreciate the opportunity
to partner with Dott.
Next, I'll be sharing
exciting product announcements
for Firestore.
Firestore is committed to
the security and privacy
of our customers.
To demonstrate that
commitment, I'm
excited to announce
four new features.
With Data Access Audit Logs,
privileged administrators
will be able to audit
all operations conducted
on a database.
With custom IAM,
customers will be
able to align
Firestore permissions
to their organization's
IAM roles.
You can get started with Data
Access Audit Logs and custom
IAM today.
With VPC Service
Controls, customers
will be able to reduce
exfiltration risk using network
level security controls.
And with App Check,
customers will
be able to ensure only signed
and pre-authorized client
applications are allowed to
make requests to Firestore.
Both the previews of VPC
Service Controls and App Check
will be rolling out in Q4.
Firestore's developer
experience truly sets it apart,
and we are continually
investing in this area.
With Key Visualizer,
customers will
be able to quickly
identify performance issues
with a visual
performance profiling.
With the latest
version of our Web SDK
we have added tree
shaking, which
enables the reduction of the
SDK footprint by as much as 80%.
That means faster load
times for your application.
Both Key Visualizer
and the new Web SDK
are generally available today.
We'll also be graduating with
Unity and C++ SDKs to general
availability in Q4.
Both of these SDKs are
focused on making it easier
to develop mobile
games using Firestore.
Lastly, I'm excited to
announce the graduation
of Cloud Functions Triggering
to general availability.
Cloud Functions
Triggering enables
customers to execute custom
business logic in response
to changes to a
Firestore document.
This session is
coming to an end,
but I hope this was just the
beginning of a shared journey.
If you want to take a moment to
try Firestore out for yourself,
you can take a peek
at our quick start
guides, YouTube [INAUDIBLE]
series, and Qwiklabs.
If you have additional
questions about using Firestore,
we encourage you to post those
questions on Stack Overflow.
My name was Minh.
And I hope that you
enjoyed today's session.
If you did, please take
a moment to fill out
the follow-up survey.
Bye for now.